today on stick to football we have a
very special guest lined out for you
it's just me and Connor today Matt's out
but Connor I think we might have found a
replacement here we're joined by Luke
Voight Starr former baseman from the New
York Yankees you might have heard of
them before
Luke welcome to the show man well I mean
listen this Melo I was walking walking
downtown at Wall Street and I saw this
guy in this quarter zip with this
button-down will bring you on in so he
was like oh yeah I'm Luke boy I play for
the Yankees so here we are you're a big
guy you look like you've probably played
a little bit in your day you want to
come apply for a podcasting job you know
that I'm getting ready for the Scouting
Combine I don't know where's your 40 at
right now oh if I put 50 pounds on then
I'll run a good 40 how about that I
might run a 5 oh [ __ ] but we got a fun
show planned we're gonna talk about the
Heisman conversation
Luke is a big college football fan got
to sit down with him before we had a
long interview but we're gonna open
things up with the Heisman obviously
this is a no-brainer Joe Perot is
leading the pack
chase young is there just as teammate
Justin fields Jalen hurts that's Luke's
favorite player from Oklahoma Hobie
there so we're gonna have a lot of fun
let's start with mellow mellow do you
think this was the right for guys to
come to New York for the Heisman I do
like these four guys Connor we just saw
Joe broke your [ __ ] in the SEC
championship game I really like him
obviously he has to be there chase young
I love what he's done all year that's
our defense for Heisman guy when you get
to the other two quarterbacks it almost
felt like we need to have four guys
there Jalen Hurd's has had a good season
Justin Fields has had a really good
season they're on playoff teams right
here all represent and I think that's
what it is
maybe we could have got a guy like
Jonathan Taylor I may be true but
Hubbard maybe even one of those Clemson
guys because Trevor Lawrence has been
playing outside of his mind recently but
I do like the four that they picked I
think Trevor Lawrence and/or Johnson
Taylor should have taken John Hurt's a
spot in my opinion that's just my
personal opinion
there's a reason clemson is
is in the final four right Trevor
Lawrence yep
Jonathan Taylor was running over all of
the national country and rushing yards
everything and then they lose and then
boom he just gets second to everyone
because he's not a part of the national
yeah the national flower for yeah and I
think Connor you mentioned it this week
if he were to win if they would have won
the Big Ten I think Jonathan Taylor gets
in obviously and there's no question
about it which sucks because this isn't
a team award it's an individual award no
it's a [ __ ] it's a [ __ ] Final
Four whoever wins wins that's why you're
the you're the Heisman Trophy winner so
do you think there's a problem with both
fields and chase young being in it do
you think there should be one team
represented no we talked about this on
your show earlier
III think chase Young is the best player
in college folk going down without a
doubt you heard it but defense even
though defense wins championships as
everyone says I think that's false
you need the you have to have the best
quarterback or you have the best running
back in my opinion and that's why I put
Jonathan Taylor up there and that's why
I put you know like Joe burrow I agree
should win it but I don't think he
should win it like it does that make
sense like you're going by the structure
of how the award is handed out correct
you're like I believe I do believe like
you have your final four playoff right
that there should be a Heisman out of
that because they got their team to the
Final Four and it's like Tom Brady won a
Super Bowl
so Tom Brady has won six Super Bowls so
he's not saying he's the best player but
he got his team and to have the best
team you have to have the not to say the
best quarterback we have to have that
guy that leads the force yes the guy
wants six so I mean that's what I'm
saying Joe burrow has the best team in
the country that's why he's gonna win
the Heisman now if he now if he doesn't
win it the college football playoff now
I might beat my worst but I you know I
mean that's why I believe like he's in
it so let me ask you guys this
both Melo and Luke do you think chase
Young is better at being a defensive end
or do you think Joe burrow is better at
being
back when it's that simplified I'm gonna
go chase young yeah there we go yeah
Luke I feel like we have a lot in common
here buddy but I'm gonna agree with you
guys
he's killed everybody all year what you
can do you can't block him with three
people No
okay easy easy on three people but um my
thing is like so wait what are the final
four matchups again a house a place
comes in right yeah yeah and then LSU I
think Clemson beats Ohio State me too on
record right now yeah wherever Lawrence
comes back and finds his way back in the
Heisman vote even though it doesn't
exist I think has our Trevor Lawrence is
the best quarterback in the next ten
years especially in the big moment I
mean we saw last year I think Trevor
Lawrence deserves all this stuff I even
though he started out like he was awful
and everyone just like oh dude the guy
want
he took Kelly Bryant spot and I saw wit
Kelly Bryant did it Mizzou not that
great but she won a national
championship as a freshman sure 19 years
old had a sophomore slump to start this
year a lot of pressure on him yeah even
though his stats weren't that bad and
all sudden he liked three like 12
touchdowns like one interception in his
next like eight weeks and he did
phenomenal so why is everybody off
Trevor Lawrence that's my personal
opinion because we live in a world
because it's the ACC it's DC yeah yeah
these guys playing in the ACC the
schedule is not great he's able to beat
up on some nobodies and people will
mention what Clemson doesn't play
anybody well Ohio State had some pretty
weak games too Joe Burrell was able to
pick on some guys not good schools and
they patted their numbers chase young
even missed two games where he could
have had some great numbers but I do
think you're right Trevor Lawrence
why do you miss those games though
[Music]
reasons kidnap cache mode yeah yeah yeah
in two years that's not even a problem
anymore
no welcome that's all right so I got a
problem with that so I'm all about it
but the problem is is that there's going
to be 10
good teams and that's gonna be it
because those sin teams are gonna be
able to afford all the guys yeah you
think you think there's a cause gonna be
it's gonna be like USC Notre Dame
Florida State Florida you know Texas
Alabama yada yada yada yada Georgia
those are the teams are gonna pay the
guys and those are the if I'm a Nike rep
or adidas or Under Armour or you know
Gatorade whatever sponsorship Wall
Street that's Ramat yeah he's the big
one that's where I'm gonna go too
am I not right I'm not I mean it's spot
on it
I mean Melo you can run away where you
play for the New York Yankees and they
can pay more than almost anybody but
that doesn't always mean success on the
field so I think that college football
will be very similar where you can't go
out and you can buy some certain
recruits but you're also gonna get those
guys that come through they really want
to build a program you're gonna get that
odd year that the Kansas City Royals
compete and win a World Series but yeah
I think you are right the traditional
powers are gonna be able to pay they're
gonna stay the traditional powers but
we've seen that in college football for
a hundred years the rich get richer and
I think that's gonna be literal case
once they do pass these laws but I still
think we'll get some teams may be in
there every once in awhile that can
compete even right now nobody's
competing with Alabama they're not
competing with Clemson and Ohio State so
it might get worse but I still think
it'll kind of stay the same a little bit
because players will want to go to
programs at college basketball I think
it's gonna set it on fire I think it's
gonna be completely different but
college football I think that'll stay
pretty much the same college basketball
is gonna the shoe deals are gonna be
ridiculous oh yeah but college football
I like I mean we're talking about to
earlier and I think too it should be the
first overall pick you cannot take a guy
the guys 100% but like another guy like
if you're going to like recruiting
processes like you have this guy come in
he's signing this thousand dollar 100
thousand dollar Nike deal and then boom
he gets hurt you know just like to it
like if ii would have taken that like
he's gone and all the sudden you got
over like
so like what guys gonna want to replace
them you know no one a guy's got this
deal at your university so how is that
gonna work you know I mean so why
wouldn't he want to go to to Auburn or
maybe Texas A&M or you know to frickin
USC or wherever so like how is that part
gonna work to where oh that guy's got a
great deal for three years so I'm not
going to that school so maybe maybe
it'll work out I don't know like if
they're gonna give him one year deals
two-year deals through your deals like
how the part how is that parking workout
I think that's a great point actually
that I hadn't thought of yeah but you're
right I mean those guys are gonna be
locked in for three years like it to uh
say that he goes there he's locked in
for three years I'm probably gonna want
to go to like a smaller school and try
to get my money out of smaller school
might not be as much as Alabama can
offer me but at least I'm not a backup
city and waiting you you have to
remember the home that you that guys out
of high school and we all know they're
taking something right now right they're
all getting offered Auburn Alabama
Michigan whatever USC well I'm gonna say
whatever on the table money right it's
just part of the game how are you not
chasing the money like how are you not
but then it's gonna be like hey if you
want this sort of money like you have to
stay for three years or hey if you don't
want this to have money you have to stay
for this year like there's gonna be
right there's got to be written go sense
it's that is that a part of it or am I
am I am I [ __ ] I don't know I think
that legislation is gonna have to do
something and they've already talked
about putting their hand in it a little
bit and try to regulate it I don't know
if they will be able to as much as they
want to but I mean money is already
flowing under the table I mean I'm sure
that as ion wasn't going to do core you
know guys that are going to Alabama
somehow always end up in these really
nice sports cars I think maybe now it
just comes to light and people actually
see the money that they're getting
I mean I it's a there's a lot of details
that need to be written out that's what
makes it so complicated there's been a
lot of instant reactions to it which
makes it interesting but I think at the
end of the day the point stands that I
mean you could list out 10 to 12 schools
that are gonna dominate from this
because the funds are there and those
are there you see them there's two teams
in each power five conference yes that
are just gonna dominate four yeah and
then an independent like Notre Dame will
always be in the picture because they
have stupid money to throw around
but Notre Dame also has a certain amount
of scholarships cuz they're Catholic
school yeah did you ever know that yeah
so they can't that's why they can't go
over the edge no and that's why they
hover around yes they're always in the
playoff picture and then that shocking
loss and then they do just hover in the
rankings they're never always get those
power five guys but they don't get them
and everywhere they get them at a couple
positions yeah all right all right we're
gonna take a break I got to sit down
with Luke for a while and of course
after that interview we're gonna close
out the show with your draft on draft
questions for this week welcome back
everyone to stick to football and we are
very happy to be joined by a special
guest today New York Yankees first
baseman D H home run hitting slugger
Luke Voigt and Luke what's going on man
thank you for joining us first off not
much man glad to be back in the city you
know I've been back in st. Louis whose
last couple months with the holidays
around and it's good to be back in the
city man so I need to get this off the
top embarrass here we go for a long time
let's go before we sat down to do this
show I got my ass kicked
we ran out but twice and the bet was is
actually a pretty pretty loose bet was
one shot and this is Luke's version of
one shot not terrible but I owe it to
him so here we go Luke can narrate he's
worried I'm gonna throw up on him yeah
so I kept them in in very good distance
I'll aim that way but yeah I gotta admit
it I got my ass kicked and hoarse so
here we go
thumbs up ah need a minute oh he's got
Jason see that's where I know he saw but
you got to host the show
I'm trying to keep that throat nice and
you know wet for you so just so everyone
knows the New York Yankees have a pretty
serious fantasy football league and it's
semaa it's semifinals Lucas in them but
before we get into any of that I need to
know who is in this league who's the
biggest [ __ ] talker what are the stakes
of this league just break it down for us
right now all right so well the forgive
you the final four right now it's
actually Guardi I'm actually family's
back he's back so it's good to have him
back
Tommy Kenley who I'm facing let me pull
this up real quick and I believe it's
Zach Britton okay Zach Britton is in it
so it is Britton verse Gardner and then
miiverse Cain Lee here we go baby what
was this in place when you got to the
team or is this something you were a
part of starting yeah so last year I
I helped Lance Lynn in the draft when
was a part of the team I was too late
you know they kind of set this stuff up
you know throughout the summer
but yeah set up the night you know we
had this like kind of draft party
whatever hotel we're at first year we're
in Oakland and last year I think we did
we did in Boston yeah we have like this
big party it's kind of cool you know on
a day off or something like that and
yeah man it's a lot of fun it's a fun
lead to be and there's a lot of [ __ ]
talking like you said yeah who's the
biggest [ __ ] talker in this league
number 11 okay I was gonna guess you
because I just played horse with them
and actually you were you were fine it
was fine but I got it was fine I was
being that was being nice so Luke is the
type of guy where he's like I'm horrible
basketball
I'm terrible not true I'm terrible yeah
basketball sinks every single shot and
the reason you're here today obviously
also is that you love football and this
is a football show and we want to talk
about football and I got to ask you I
know I've read some stories you
originally wanted to play football do
you want full ball and I know you had
some injuries but just what was the and
your brother was the captain of army
very recently I grew up near that's why
he's wearing his army green it's right I
mean
a little bias but just like did you grow
up a fan of an NFL team or a college
team I know you're from Missouri yeah so
grew up a huge Rams fan okay so the last
couple years have been pretty shitty for
me yeah so I lost them you know and that
was kind of the same time that you know
fantasy football got big for me that's
when I started putting some money into
the fantasy football and yeah the Rams
broke my heart and I tried hopping on
the Chiefs bandwagon I got a bunch of
buddies that are Chiefs fans and from
because I went to Missouri State which
is you know kind of split in between yep
you know st. Louis in Kansas City so
that's when I had Alex Smith I can't get
on Alex Smith bandwagon it so of course
they draft mahomes the year after him
Holmes has become his MVP stud and then
this year I tried to be actually for our
draft party I wore a sandbar Z because
everyone gets to Jersey okay so I was
trying to hop on the mono boy but yeah
it's off Julian I got I was like you
know what it's fine they lose I think
they lost week one or some like that and
that was like you know what you know
sudden he misses a month and I'm like
yeah Luke Fox hard to watch every week I
grew up which I'm from here I grew up a
Jets fan it was a miserable month and
I'm like man this is just reminds me of
the Rams again listen I went through
flight forints well I mean they're five
and a right now but you know just for
two four six wins a year I couldn't do
it so I'm and then it makes me want to
become a cheese fan again because Chiefs
just going to beat the freakin Patriots
but I don't know man this this this game
just lets me off balance sometimes with
you know what happens so but I don't
know I don't have a team right now but
college football diehard Mizzou fan I
was all up on the killer Bryant training
this year you know obviously I know that
guy bounce men juries but you know
opening you can't lose to Wyoming week
one and then you know we go 5-1 filing
it ranked again and then we lost four in
a row so can't lose to Kentucky
can't lose to Vandy and the SEC those
are the you know the teams you got a
beat but you know I'm still Mizzou fan
and you know we got drink which from
Appalachian State recently so I'm pretty
hyped about that you know we gave him a
nice little deal and he's out the
recruit and so let's see what some good
things happen yeah it's a new era for
Mizzou which i think is exciting and I
think we'll find Luke and NFL
team because I think when you know this
show Pat mahomes is actually our guest
of the year we love Pat so maybe we'll
have Pat convince you to jump on the the
Chiefs Kingdom yeah I mean I would like
actually went I went to a game two weeks
ago okay
great environment beat the [ __ ] out of
the Raiders yeah yeah I would usually if
you guys don't go if you guys want to go
to like one of the best environments as
you go to achieve tailgate is
unbelievable
cuz the Chiefs and Royals do you know
they share a huge parking lot it's you
know about 20 minutes from outside the
city unbelievable yeah and you know
that's rated the best you know NFL
stadium and in the country just with the
noises and yeah wild absolutely Wow and
so back to the Rams though I I do find
that interesting they're one of the
teams that when they packed up and left
like the fans did not go with them which
and that was the case for you right they
had also been there before so yeah but
no I still know people in st. Louis who
are still Rams fans but I would say 90%
of them hate the Rams so I know you're a
Missouri guy originally what's your
offseason been like when you go back
home I know you're recovering from
injury but what is your typical
offseason schedule like well you know I
had the surgery this year so the first
six weeks I've been doing rehab and I
just got out of rehab last week yeah
sounds like I'm not behind yeah yeah I
just got out of got done doing that I'm
actually clear to go now I've gotten all
the baseball activities back in course
so now it's just you know pretty much
Monday through Friday I'm working out
weekends I take off and then once you
know the New Year hits that's when I'll
start getting back into base blocked if
--'tis and you know rubbing that part up
but for right now it's just working out
you know I'm kind of just getting back
and seeing family and friends and stuff
and you know doing all those meet and
greets you know coming back up here kind
of you know just playing basketball
playing basketball against the worst
basketball players I've ever had it's
pretty rough y marketing Patrick Powell
I'll throw his name out there he's
obvious he was he was telling us how
great he was at basketball and cheese I
mean oh yeah it was it's always good win
I'm joking Patrick I love it when you're
not the worst guy on the court that's
why I'm glad Patrick was here yeah the
guy in green is only the worst player
it was it was good for that you know
I've been here my entire life and I
don't think there's only been a couple
guys like you where I've seen the fans
just welcomed you with open arms
and it's crazy I mean they really really
do love you what is that and I know you
grew up a Cardinals fan right yeah and
you're in the Cardinal system but what
does that Bend like when you get traded
here and you instantly become so loved
and just a part of honestly a historic
franchise and I say that as a Mets fan
but it's a historic franchise yeah no
man it's you know from when I first got
here I wasn't opening good arms I kind
of stuck to right when I got here but
from what I've received from these fans
and you know I get these Luke chants
everywhere I go you know whether it's
here you know we go to LA or wherever we
go it's it's unbelievable and you know
I'm a you know lunch-pail kind of guy
man I go to work I work my butt off you
know I'm gonna show up every day and you
know give you guys the best of the
ability and I'm gonna play with charisma
too and I think that's what a lot of
guys like and a lot of the fans like is
you know the energy I kind of bring and
that's something I'm always gonna bring
and I love playing here man like I even
though it's it's it's frustrating
sometimes playing it from the cameras
you know a lot of guys don't want that
to you know good or bad game you got 50
cameras in front of a sigh it's
something that's part of it and it's you
know obviously with you know more media
growing and baseball progressing and
stuff it's gonna get more and more like
that and I mean look at us now this
would have been like this ten years ago
but it's fun I
it just shows people what I like we're
talking about you know we're talking
about baseball right now but we're gonna
talking about football like this yeah
stuff that I'm going back home I have
two TVs on my wall back home I got the
redzone on I got the local game on like
I love football too like that's a
passion of mine it brings out you know I
get to show you guys we can talk about
football like whatever you know like
it's I'm not just a guy that wears a
pinched Ryu 162 games a year you know
I'm a person too and I want to show you
guys well I think we know that from the
viral videos of you lifting which I'm a
gigantic fan of but also the football
aspect which you know our fans of stick
to football would love to hear about me
and you were just bullshitting before
the show
obviously the Heisman ceremony is gonna
include jobber Oh Jalen Hurd's chase
young Justin Fields we were talking
about Jonathan Taylor I know you're a
big college football fan I think it'd be
crazy to vote for anyone but jobber oh
right now I would you agree with that
for the Heisman III I think he's gonna
be unanimous but I don't think he should
be I think it's just he's in the Animus
or unanimous because of what LSU has
done this year okay
and I feel like that's how it always
goes it does and like we were talking
earlier I think Jonathan Taylor should
have been instead of Jalen Hurd's
yep and I I mean I think chase Young's a
beast - yeah I mean they're never gonna
give it to defensive guy yep but I mean
the guy's gonna be a top five pick
number one number two burrow go number
one
so you think Jason you're not holding
out for two at all
I look and I love to uh see we're gonna
go fold your ass right now just buckle
up we're like I love baseball we're
ditching it right now
I really do because I think here's the
thing the Bengals are picking number one
like they've set themselves up enough
and even if the Giants are awful enough
to find their way into that the Bengals
so he'll be number two and move up or
they'll sit there I think him being a
mr. Ohio it's just such an easy sell to
the fan base but to his medicals if he
comes back at the combine where they go
he's gonna go full recovery he's gonna
be a top five pick still you're right so
I mean his injuries aren't related to
his arm yes and he's still gonna be
mobile yeah so why would you not ID so
I'm just saying he has a track record
okay that been like if he would've broke
his ankle or something you're telling me
you're not gonna take him just because
you broke his ankle or like I'm not
because it wasn't a boat accident yeah
it's not what everybody kept saying it's
the worst it comes down and they go this
is bo Jackson all over again and then
they tied him to the fact that oh he's
had injury problems before whether it's
the ankle or this or that it's football
it's both you're gonna get hurt you're
gonna get hurt it happens and I think
with - uh I selling - is the best
quarterback in this class would you
agree I agree I just I I agree I think
Joe Broz - I love that it's as simple as
that
now when you look at this back to the
Heisman conversation because I was
interested in this with Jonathan Taylor
we do something on the show called
defense for Heisman we
you fully believe in that it's become a
quarterback award or a running back
award it's basically the best
quarterback or running back on the
undefeated team every single year and I
think it's come to a point where they
need to distinguish Awards where is it
the best player in college football or
is it the best quarterback and running
back on the best theme would you agree
with that yes but it people like when
you're watching the national
championship game and I'm gonna go this
like kind of both aspects you want to
see the Heisman playing right of course
you do
so that's what they're going for but
that's a matter what sells money exactly
it's so but we don't do that on here no
I know I I I agree I think chase Young
is the best player I mean you saw at the
Penn State game saw on the Michigan game
you don't walk into 16 and a half sacks
that's what I'm saying the big 10 I
agree because all those linemen are 3 45
6 6 6 25 every Wisconsin house state
Penn State Iowa wherever you go and
you're going against the best I would
say the product I mean SEC is the best
conference in my opinion yeah it is the
Big Ten's right behind just doesn't have
the impact players like the the wide
receiver isn't like it's like that yeah
your your fantasy players how about that
no that's a great way to put it when it
and that's how everybody stacks the
board even the underclassmen I mean you
look at Alabama with Jalen Waddell you
look at LSU with chase it's it's just a
system where they just have guy after
guy after guy but I think with chase
young the argument can be teams know who
he is
like Nick Bosa got hurt last year so it
was chase young steam it's eating coming
to this here and surprise any know for
sure so he's getting doubled he's
getting tripled he's still affecting the
game I do want to you know kind of get
your opinion on the NFL right now
because there's so many opinions on the
quarterbacks and getting away from
college football who do you think the
NFL MVP has been because right now you
like everybody's saying Lamar Jackson
Russell Wilson
yeah I I was gonna say I think Russell
even though I don't know what the hell
happened to him on Sunday Night Football
but yeah
the Rams were do that that's it's like
that yeah I mean honestly it's just like
cuz I
thing I'm not just hating on the Rams
but I'm gonna from my aspect of like
they just been losing losing and they
they beat the Cardinals finally yeah
everyone's like okay you know they're
hanging in the playoff race yeah and
then the Seahawks I've just been you
know they barely beat the Falcons you
know they barely beat smaller teams but
they beaten some good teams and Russell
was just his offensive lines kind of
scrambling they lost their Center for
the year they've lost a couple of our
guys like how many times did we see this
story with Russell though and I thought
he was gonna pull it back there was like
four minutes left in the fourth quarter
when they were playing when they're
putting the ran Sunday and I thought I
was gonna do and then he ended up not
doing it but yeah even the announcer
Chris Collins was talking about it but I
think that point alone describes how we
should look at Russell where we're
accustomed to it every time that he has
no offensive line or I mean I know
Rashad Penny just got hurt for the year
but whether it's no skill players around
him you know they lose their tight ends
he finds a way to get it done austere
dudes killing for him so yeah yes
Hollister's been great they obviously
they haven't gotten Josh Gordon involved
a lot but they still have three wide
receivers that have been very productive
it's healthy now I know and lock it
every year sits on our draft board and
I'm like I mean okay except they talk
like it's amazing I just when they got
on the hot streak like I'm six weeks ago
I put in like a five-dollar like seattle
superbowl bet because the odds were so
embarrassingly low where you look at
them and i'd read had this conversation
with Sean Alexander last week SEC
Championship he goes because Seattle is
so tucked away people do not value Russ
for what he is like they don't look at
him like Aaron Rodgers they don't look
at him on Brady
I almost feel like it's like so like
last year like when the ransoms Patriots
win Super Bowl I was like you can't bet
against town yeah just can't and or do I
feel against what I'm betting if I were
bet against rust like I can't bet
against them I feel like no matter what
even if the spreads higher low like he's
gonna give you a close game or he's
gonna try to he's gonna win the game
somehow like they're gonna pull
something he's almost a magician he's
gonna pull something off his hat and I
think that's what makes him special that
no matter what time the game he'll be
Russell Wilson actually he was my hawk
remains spring training this year I got
I didn't even I didn't even think about
to me
this year it was very brief he might not
remember me he's a big-time guy you know
he's got here and everything I mean
don't sell yourself short here a new
start for the New York Yankees let's
just get this out of the way I know like
enough of this small Missouri like 2020
second round twenty college yeah I know
you're thirty second out of high school
yeah like the odds of that are like
below five percent yeah and I know but
he's Russell Wilson you want Superboy as
MVP yeah I mean I don't know it seems
pretty cool I was kind of starstruck it
is sick and is that I got to ask you is
that like more of a a show or does he
come in like I'm gonna show people I
could still play baseball you know it's
funny cuz like you know we during spring
training it's you know we're doing base
running drills yeah we're you know
taking BP we're doing outfield we're
getting fieldwork pitchers throwing pens
you know kinda everyone's separated in
their positions and all the infielders
had to go we are like in like a group so
like you know like guys would have to do
base running drills which we still do
I'm 28 years old and I'm still doing
base train drills just like so you guys
alright no I mean it's it's literally
like you don't understand how much like
you know three inches and a foot makes
and that's what it does become how you
you know round the bases how your leads
are how your secondaries are like if
you're trying to steal like no I'm not
trying to steal but you know like yeah I
think it's time
number one it's coming yeah it's coming
but it was kind of cool like he he came
out for that he puts the cleats on and
he was doing our base when in droves
with us and I was like of all the things
that I would do if I was Russell Wilson
I would not be doing the base renewals I
would be trying to be hit homeruns in BP
yeah take BP yeah hit a couple feet yeah
do couple of no swinging miss and then
yeah yeah where the he was doing the
small stuff like I mean he was like
embedded in it like loved it like I
think it just brought back the stuff
that he did in college and even when he
did the stuff in Texas that it was kind
of cool but I think that kind of shows
the preparation like the mentality of
him where it's like it's oh he's always
on in a way when sports are going on so
positive yeah it is in in professional
sports in my opinion it the hardest
thing to do outside of hitting a
fastball or something like that yes
the mentality of it and being positive
because it is so hard especially with
our world with social media and you know
just you know your life on the stake
money on the stake like all this stuff
and people keep performing progressing
and always find a positive and negative
is the hardest thing to do and that's
what separates the best you know but the
greats better than the average guy I
mean every little thing is analyzed
that's the thing nowadays like like
every at-bat it's stewed it's it's it's
crazy I mean you detach yourself from
that during the season right you have to
you have to it's so hard sometimes you
want to delete your Twitter Instagram
yeah it's some guys do honestly I have
guys in here that are like yeah don't
sweet or somebody runs the account or
you know what I mean Instagram well
yesterday I tweeted about the Gerrit
Cole cause he's number forty which is
hilarious yeah so I thought it was kind
of funny even though I can't freaking
write or spell anymore but but yeah just
like it's just I want to tweet so much
about so much stuff too and I just
sometimes like it's not worth it no it R
is the risk of it being blown up is so
weird no because someone will make it I
don't want to say like you know like
they'll take it the wrong way
yeah and then all sudden someone thinks
I'm this type of person so that's that
person it's like I'm losing fans and I'm
like I said at all I mean I host the
podcast and we get reviews that are like
why don't you talk about the Panthers or
why you know and not just the Panthers
but and on your skin it was gonna be
Chicago Bear uh maybe
would you like to fit kissing titties is
back though he's PS I mean he lit it up
Thursday night in his sense if he is not
a pocket passer as long as he runs he's
good man it's it's hard to put a lot of
faith know like I'm sorry it's just it's
hard you know if you're Chicago they
know but they're gonna I guarantee they
make the playoffs somehow and they watch
they win a game or some like that oh I
think the quarterback I don't think it's
crazy at all no but like the problem
with teams is they sell themselves on
quarterbacks so
easily like Mark Sanchez got an
extension here the 29 2010 Jets
we're not builds on Mark Sanchez and
that's just one example of a million but
the problem is the quarterback market is
just so bad like Teddy I don't think
Teddy's gonna go there when you look at
the free agents you have Teddy I rivers
might hang it up but like it everyone's
saying Brady's gonna go to LA I don't
maybe I'm not really buying it we hear
stuff about Brady every year yeah where
it's like but the problem with Brady is
he if New England is done with him he'll
just keep playing I think yeah Cam's
gone I don't know I I'm not really sold
on khylin but I think now they're ready
to the flip switch especially firing Ron
which I thought was super surprising
very it's more of a new owner wanting
like his guy but that doesn't always
make it the right decision and I think
um I mean I just
Kris McCaffrey's abuse me yeah he's best
running back in the NFL right he's the
best player in the NFL yeah okay I think
so really
yes when you go through it in your head
it's hard to tell me someone better
outside of I say Ross what impactful if
anyone's gonna say anything about Marv
Jackson yeah probably but I mean but
have you like he's yeah he's averaged
almost a hundred all-purpose yards every
game again yeah the amount of touches he
can handle I mean he could play
literally wide receiver and running back
that's what's great like people don't
understand how he's like LT dude yeah I
think that's fair I think that's really
he's just on a bad team yes he gets his
he it's like going to 4/4 a home run but
you lose five to two nobody ever looks
that's the only saying nobody ever
laughs but if you go 1 for 5 with the
home run in the ninth inning you're the
star of the game I should I got four
times but then I hit the ground Homer
strikeouts don't even matter
yeah I know but I'm so I'm saying like
literally be the most worst affective
out in history of baseball four times
their own then I hit their own home run
everybody forgets about it I have to say
like one of the most you hold something
that's one of the most valuable things
in this state right now is you sitting
next to me and you brought it up before
that's the number 45 Jersey
I mean really like it's one of the most
valuable things in the world I don't
know about that uh I mean if I was
wearing number 99 it would be a little
different the man that wants number 45
will get three hundred twenty four
million dollars I always laugh at that
because we live in New York the taxes
you cut it in half one thing where does
the where does that let's build an offer
like what it what is one thing you've
always wanted dream what's our dream car
what's the dream car
I knew we're gonna get into this man I
don't know man I will say here we go
last year I'm not gonna go off what I
want me and him will figure that out and
I'll be a story for another day
fair enough so to locate last year right
okay yeah of course and he gave he
wanted tearaway Jersey and that was
twelve I think twelve twelve twelve in
something maybe twelve and ten they'd
switched off or whatever and he took and
- Oh got a Rolex
that's pretty I mean it's it's nice but
you sign for 324 dude you got more
leverage than that like I had written
dit like you don't have to answer any of
this but this is what I had written down
that I the list of dream car exotic pet
vacation home I would say dream car
exotic spec you know I have a dog dogs
my exact that's exotic pet vacation
homes pretty sweet yeah I mean we're
talking about 320 for me he's making a
million dollars of started so maybe that
could be something yes and I mean a new
chain would be nice you talking about a
Rolex but a new chain would be I just
bought a new chain subs all right so
we're done with that yeah man
I like like the person third one it's
okay yeah we're gonna we're gonna figure
that out
well there's a lot of time for that he
didn't even Sweetman bags kind of maybe
that's a little [ __ ] up
honestly it's okay that's alright we'll
become become he's trying to swim at
okay I'm here for nine years - well
honestly though went because I always
talk to the NFL guys about this and they
are very overwhelmingly positive is that
something you're watching at all or just
happens and you're like oh great like
let's go no I mean I get the updates but
it's definitely something I mean I've
been
in so many conversations about how many
people have asked me about Gerrit Cole
and I was like great like ya know but I
was like yep we're getting him okay like
that was something I like knew yeah that
was something I expected you know I
think that was one of the reasons we are
not one of the reasons one of the things
that we needed that we didn't have last
year kind of thing yeah frontline ace
yeah James is unbelievable Tanakh is
unbelievable we just didn't have that
guy and like you look at the two teams
that made it and there was you know
Scherzer in Strasburg and then :
Berliner yeah I mean and I it we've just
been so close and I wasn't here in 17
but we've been so close that you know
they had to make a splash and I and
everyone keeps making these boss remarks
and I think it's it was a it was a
perfect move yeah I mean listen Boston
this time brand that's what I meant
of course yeah it's it's hard to have
any problems with that alright so
getting away getting away from baseball
again because I mean enough of baseball
right we're getting doing this fight so
hey Juan I got some questions yeah let's
go through I mean you said before the
show you're like I might need some help
from you guys - all right so Kirk
Cousins or Jimmy Garoppolo this week
Jimmy G is a juicy matchup I think yeah
Hotlanta I mean that secondary has been
Swiss cheese I know and do you want to
hurry Cousins has been carrying me for
the last like I know yeah but no no no
like previous bison fantasy it's a
week-to-week game until week two we came
that's it
I mean I'm gonna tell you Jimmy G Jimmy
G's projected a lot more even though I
hate projections but projections are
garbage just are you yahoo or ESPN uh
CBS Wow that's something you don't hear
a lot I'm literally in four leagues all
different four leagues is this the
Yankees league yeah all the stakes for
this are is it's just [ __ ] talking or is
there any kind of fun thing involved oh
there's a lot okay yeah all right we
could keep that hush-hush I don't so
it's alright so you said Jimmy G and
tweet tweet at Luke like every gal
I need help I mean I got going against
I'm going against my meatball and Tommy
came Lee so I got it I got it whoop his
ass this week I mean this show comes out
you all right so I also have James
Conner who has been not good not her
playing
he was my first round pick I'm even
lucky to get to this point yeah
and he's supposed to be back this week
do I play him instead of Devin
Singletary Buffalo really likes him
though or Kareem hunt and Kareem hunts
been putting up a steady like 12 13 yeah
he has it's crazy that like within an
area up there they still and they're
playing Arizona who's probably worse
defensive football that's a tricky and
that's just so I have running bangers
that flex too
so my running back right now I've cream
hunt my Flex I have Singletary and then
on my bench I have freaking tea why
Hilton and James Conner it's hard to
give it an tackle gallop I was it was
really good right is a PPR
yes okay this just got a lot more
difficult I think I'm out on James I'm
playing James Conner I think I am too
like I get it closer on defense is good
very good very the thing I hate those
it's Sunday Night Football
yeah which makes him if he wants to play
he's gonna play good yeah it makes you
play the waiting game and it's at
Pittsburgh which you know like the home
retire and then if I look at my bench
he's got 25 points I may be like and
with duck Hodges there so you could sell
yourself into these into the ship I
actually picked up Boston Scott - who
was the hero of Monday Night Football
who's supposed to start I mean I I mean
I don't know cuz what's the name scenery
right yeah I think he's gonna play those
get a play though yeah he's gonna play
in the prop make them up for emergency
the problem with that is Jordan Howard
might be back so I have him like you're
walking into like the trifecta no I
picked the magician you know you don't
know you don't know if you need them
finals week where is our confidence
level right now of winning in the semis
in the Yankees league the CBS League
I was 11 and 3 this year okay 11 to 3
right now is 10 3 wait who's the worst
what's up yeah I need to know who's
embarrassing and is there a last place
punishment because that's like actually
our pitching coach Michael Harkey ok
second the last the Cameron Maybin not a
great look for Cameron Maybin no I'm
sorry Campbell OE bro well I don't know
I think I I don't know I don't think you
can go no no man so what do you think so
what so I got so right now a lot of his
cousin's cook I hope so Cousins is
penciled in over Jimmy G no I have
cousins in yeah so I've had I'm all
about to Liz oh I'm all about the
Minnesota Vikings this year ok
[Music]
I got cousins cook and I've been leaning
on Devin Singletary a lot since he came
back
I'm killing it yeah he's right I got
Stefon Diggs - I have Tony I'm missile
Vikings and everybody he was that guy
that just sat there and sat there yeah
and sat there and I didn't even draft I
directed I drafted Baker Mayfield this
year and I thought Baker was gonna kill
it but that isn't it great all the
quarterbacks though that were drafted
high like Rogers hasn't had this stat
field year yeah my home's got hurt so
I'll tell you who was a guy that killed
it for me though at the end was killed
it for him this year who I kind of would
took a risk on was Alan Robinson yeah so
he's well so I have days Robinson's from
our series I've Zach Hertz who's had a
if a year Harrison bucker and then you
know the defense's you know I just in
and out I think you're in a pretty good
spot
I don't think you can go really wrong
with cousins or Jimmy G but I've had
gallop step up for me I've had Connor
step he's done nothing for me he was
away so a first-round pick
so when you get back and cook save my
team this year oh you have Dalvin I had
that made up for your first round pick
up Connor yeah he was my second round
pick I went running back running back in
my opinion the way to do a league is you
gotta go running back round you have to
there's no one else you have two
receivers you can just stack up on
you've got someone late whatever nobody
takes quarterbacks in the first five
rounds anymore
unless you take mahomes I guess yeah but
hones there and look how that goes and
like we love Pat but people get hurt it
happens yeah
so it's tricked by fantasy sucks it's
the worst addiction ever all right
before I get you out of here cuz I know
you have things to do and we really
appreciate you joining us kicking my ass
and a horse making me do a shot hey what
do you got on this uh this Jess Ravens
game oh I took Baltimore 14 and a half
it's hard he had like 18 okay that's I
mean no Jamal Adams who's gonna whose
job is to chase around Lamar Jackson
which he did when he was at LSU against
Louisville Lamar's gonna run for a like
a hundred and twenty yards easily it
squads messed up yeah but you don't give
a [ __ ] you didn't you're talking to the
wrong guy so I'm like a beaten down Jets
fan dude like miserable miserable it's
like a runoff and you know this from VIN
Baltimore ball throws guy the top five
yeah I mean you know this one here one
week of wearing Sam Donald you were Sam
darn Jersey and he got mono so that way
we're in the green that's right if our
Navy yeah I am wearing a fake go army
beat Navy by the way wait so I should
what's it like being the the second
toughest guy on your family yeah I'll
give my brother that my brother's the
toughest guy my family so he graduated
Ranger School so applauding after being
the captain of the army football teams
so he had to go six weeks a hell week
bro literally he put his cell phone away
went out into the middle of woods for
like six weeks now to go through some
[ __ ] and then he gets back calm I
talked to him for like three hours on
the phone pretty much catch up on life
right cuz he hasn't been on his phone
he's like yeah dude about to go through
Airborne School no [ __ ] play right I
can't this I hate Heights that's like my
that's your job like that's and he's
like this on that bed he's like yeah and
to make six jumps and one of them was in
the dark so I was like holy [ __ ] so you
don't even see where you're he goes that
was easiest landing because I think he
said you prepare for that landing like
it's like your last landing but I was
like - pitch black can't imagine what
that shows like anyway so he graduated
that Airborne School so
he's actually gonna be in New York in
Fort Benning here are not for bringing
up Jesus what's the army base up in
northern New York my blanket I don't
think in a second but okay he's gonna be
up there in a little bit and then
hopefully he doesn't get too deployed I
mean this is the second Najee places so
you guys are in the same state again I
don't when you got traded here was cool
cuz he was at West Point yeah he was
getting a bunch of free beers in the
stands great oh yeah that's got to be
pretty nice yeah damn and like also I
know he obviously he went on to play
college ball at a high level
I mean Army's really I grew up near West
Point like they've really rebuilt the
program yeah speaking of that I guess
Monken was possible Mizzou target to I
don't know how I don't I wouldn't want
that I like money in a lot too but I
just don't think that we're working the
SEC no and he's also great where he is
it's imperfect it's worse like the total
like yes sir
no ma'am like you know five o'clock 5:30
like he's that timeline guy yeah you
know like drill sergeant football coach
yes which I mean and you recruit for
that and guys will come to that but you
can't you can't do that in the SEC SEC
guys they want to go the NFL yeah for
after three years yeah like three years
and they're like okay I'm gonna get paid
correct so what was your favorite hire
so far as we've seen these last couple
of weeks I think I think it's the worst
it's a band-aid hire like splash move
you bar excited I think he's done
nothing and all of and he leaves every
year so why would you hire a guy that
keeps leaving and leaving leaving he got
this huge deal at FAU FAU yeah who gave
him money from like SEC money and he
leaves again of Court well of course he
did and then go get Willie tagger but
that's another story so you hate the
link if entire I really like from the
zoo's hire I think Mizzou hires a great
hire yep
what about Norville at Florida State oh
that's okay yeah there's risk there yeah
this guy I Memphis had a good year this
year though awesome year I mean to beat
Cincinnati
likewise not easy why back-to-back weeks
I played Memphis a lot that's where the
Triple A teams at yep it's just it's
it's a hard city it's a hard
what was your weirdest minor league
experience it's like I've heard like
weird minor-league stories weird story
or like what like the strangest place
you're at yeah that's a crazy life all
right
no but Memphis is good but I just I
actually my boat one of my brother's
best friends played a university Memphis
okay you have like some familiarity when
you got there or yeah no I mean I knew
all about it's just it's a rough city
yeah rough city I believe it and that
minor-league life is terrible what's
that yeah when you go from even from
triple-a to the majors like isn't even
the post game like food buffet like
eye-opening yeah I go from anywhere from
getting so I'm making $700 every two
weeks okay tuhhh getting like you know
like random will say a buffalo wrap yeah
your average Buffalo wrap right from you
name it or like a chicken sandwich or
you know a little fruit bowl oh thanks
after like nine innings again you know
you know filets to you know sea bass did
your New York yeah your New York City
and they take care of it I mean look how
they have him dressed right now no I was
excited I was excited because I thought
I had a fellow meathead is in May Missy
in in Maine as we addressed today we
have an event tonight
there's your promo and they do an
unbelievable job these shirts they're
button-downs right you can see it there
button-downs
and they are like athletic they're like
Nike it's like a wearing a Nike shirt
with buttons it is unbelievable and you
don't have to take in the dry cleaner
their unbelief I was like a stretch fit
yes and they're like slim fit though so
like okay so us yeah is the life of
workouts as a high comme ci I'm shooting
hoops and I have like a like a medium on
you say I wear shirt two times smaller
than that like you know no because I
always worth our ties shirts
and I need to look at myself in the
video camera right now I'm like Jesus
Christ I mean you're you were perfect to
come to New York New Jersey area because
like you're one of us
I just need you to know that hello
meatball yeah yeah your meathead the
viral lifting videos we took on their
own life are they returning when you're
fully good to go something they're not
gonna be returning because I got yelled
at or did you really I had a feeling
when they started it's quiet but they're
there they're back the one hand benching
yeah they're back you need alright so if
you guys follow me on Instagram stuff I
was saying the next couple weeks once
I'm like a hundred percent to go and all
this stuff and I'm I'm good like so this
what probably people wanna hear is so I
had the surgeries I was six weeks out
last week I didn't prompt you know I
know I know I know I I want to tell
everybody like you know I played through
this stuff last year it's a you don't
realize how bad this injury is and I
didn't either I thought I was just
reading the whole time and ended up
tearing everything down there but you
know the second half of the season last
year was pretty pretty shooted far for
me you know I didn't do very well and I
was playing through a lot and I was also
thick-headed and you know I wanted be
out there with the guys and you know I'm
gonna play through stuff just to be
there and I want to be there in the
playoffs and you know I'd even make the
playoff roster for the second round so I
was a gut check for me and I learned a
lot of lessons this year but you know
I'm gonna give it my all every year in
I'm gonna be back better than ever next
year and my trains been well and I'm
back to normal again so it feels good so
if you guys follow me on you know my
social media and stuff and I got Twitter
and Instagram i'll be i'll be posting
stuff here soon you know back in the way
room and you know in the in the cages
and stuff getting ready to go for next
year it's what the people are waiting
for yeah all right before we sign off I
had one question here that I haven't hit
on at all it could be past or present
your NFL Mount Rushmore okay I mean
you're gonna have a Rams fan so no
president no no no no yet
I agree Wow paint Manning okay I like
that you didn't start with Brady no me
get through I almost have to go
quarterbacks it's kind of bad but I
almost feel like I know Marshall Faulk
no that was that was the guy that might
I have to go Kurt Warner I'm our I love
Kurt Warner okay so Peyton Manning Kurt
Warner I said earlier today and it's
only because I got to watch him play
I'll say no you know what no I won't
gonna say him Lawrence Taylor the real
LT yeah I was gonna say ledee in
Townsend but I think L T's I've heard
stories about him and I heard he's just
was like oh the best I mean he changed
football like even Bill Belichick will
come out and say that he changed
football yeah and I heard it was like
like high school football to him oh yeah
that conversation going a lot of
different direct Barry Walter Dickerson
I
I'll say Barry Sanders because I had his
jersey on okay yeah that's how I was
gonna I was debate in between I'm not
gonna go at dickerson I'm not gonna go
all Rams but the only reason I went Kurt
Warner that guy came from nothing
yeah and he came in a foul and like he
he won he went to two Super Bowls two
different teams did he played in Europe
like could you imagine Northern Iowa
could you imagine going to Europe to
like the guy was so good had the worst
arm of all time yes he was so good one
of the smartest but we were psyched on
he was like brad Ziegler like you
through from down here
can you through like I did yeah and it
was just
in between numbers everything yeah and
for that greatest show on turf team it
was everything was pinpoint it was all
timing
everybody's Bruce Marshall [ __ ] toriel
toriel hold its and I mean you talk
about the offensive line for days
because he could sit back there and be
like alright I'm good I'm good Lando
pace one side
I mean legitimately the probably the
best song I got lucky growing up that's
why it pissed me off so much that the
Rambla of course it does and it's about
we deal with it all the time because
Raider fans are so loyal that they don't
know you know do they do they go with
the Vegas move yeah but they're going to
Vegas I mean yeah it's new it's
something trendy obviously you know the
reason why they're leaving we had the
st. Louis Cardinals and I was before I
was alive
and then they left and went to Arizona
and then we got the Rams again from LA
and then they went left and went back to
LA so it's like a previous move and
obviously they went out there for the
money but of course and I know they're
going there for the money that's the
whole process you gotta remember sports
are a business to always are and they're
gonna make business decisions and
becomes billions and billions of dollars
I know especially nowadays which people
don't get but we gonna do man yeah
that's it well thanks a lot for joining
me man there's a lot of fun yeah dude I
mean I could swallow my pride that you
absolutely kicked my ass and horse and
had to do a shot had to take a chaser
yeah fun we need to get Patrick in here
just so I just so I'm not the only loser
but you'll have to come back man
like that for sure talk some football
after baseball season we'll get back on
it we'll get back all right he's Luke
Voigt thanks for sticking with us guys
we'll be right back after this Pat
Chamberlain with the first question here
if you had to pick a 2020 late round
quarterback prospect to have a Gardner
Minshew
type impact as a rookie if gave him the
chance
who's the guy Melo you got anyone I
Jordan love declared this week and I
don't yeah I don't like him a lot but I
do think that he's a guy that has those
traits that we talked about that could
come in use his legs a little bit use
that big strong arm if he lands in the
right situation like a Gardner Minshew
maybe he goes to the bears or another
team in need of a quarterback but that
surrounded him with some good pieces I
could see him make it a good push as a
rookie outside of him who do you think I
mean I I feel like I got
I feel like it's there's like five top
five guys and after that it comes off I
mean that's pretty spot-on who do you
take after that I you said that and I
was like I can't take it I don't know
who else to take honestly I mean after
the half an ounce you get into guys like
jaylen hurt who can't really throw the
ball you just come on attention as pass
pass yeah
Nate Stanley Iowa yep KJ Costello
Stanford Shea Patterson Michigan no
another Washington State guy Anthony
Gordon ooh yeah did you see the 20 24 7
I'll show you guys then yeah I mean I'll
tell you who pulled the Gardner Minshew
I'll tell you what man like I know
people love when they fight for Anthony
Gordon they say hey man he almost beat
Gardner out in the battle he's not
Gardner no I don't see it there either
and that charisma that Gardner had he
won the Senior Bowl that whole week I
mean he's a dude that you would just
want to go out and hang out with yeah
people look at a locker room yeah he's
like a cooler version of Luke honestly I
mean I was thinking it yeah I just had
to say to [ __ ]
no but really you look at this
quarterback class and it's like we know
about Joe Burrell we know about to a
Jacob Eason might to Claire I think Jake
Fromm goes back it's not gonna be
surprises I was high on Jake abuse in he
just blew I mean [ __ ] man yep if you
would have told me day one opening
college football season I thought he
would've been a top top 3 pick [ __ ] we a
lot of book II just
but I will say his offensive line is the
worst offensive line in the SEC bull Wow
there that's it take 15
I know but dude the rest you watch his
yeah if you watch him drop back no time
yeah and I feel like he's the
quarterback that can read and my number
one thing with the quarterback and see
if you get past your first read outside
of dumping it if you get to your second
or third read then you're an NFL
quarterback oh he's a smart dude yeah
like a smart dude
yeah he's the only guy to make it
through QB 12 or QB 11 he'll be 11 yeah
he he's a smart dude like listen when he
was coming out as a freshman
there was NFL dudes they were like
that's the guy they thought that highly
of him I don't know why I like guys from
but I like Jamie Rahn I messed that up
cuz Tate Martel was on that whoa Bob
yeah
[ __ ] man they wanted to play slot
receiver now he's like the next edelman
be in your flight football hero for real
[ __ ] I don't think he's making our team
no but for real
I like Fromm for what he is I think he's
going back to school yeah I know
surprises because there's no one next
year like it we're not gonna talk about
Kelly Bryant anymore
I know yeah but you have Trevor Lawrence
this year but I'm saying like you know
next year we could talk to some sales so
maybe he's protecting themselves I don't
know give it time
so you you saying Justin feels like a
Connery kind of thing
he's in the conversation right now
how do you feel about Sam Ehlinger you
think he's a prospect he's okay yeah I
mean I'm a Texas fan but I still don't
know if he has the arm every Texas
quarterback always get stretchy like in
the six or seven surround yep just
because they're five-star because they
can they're there they have a power arm
yeah and that's it 215 they're like the
perfect size yeah man all right I hate
that I hate the Ben money Morris what
recently retired players would you guys
higher as NFL head coaches coaches
recently retired I would love to see
what Peyton Manning can do with an all I
might not know [ __ ] about these actually
you know he probably does I would like
to see what yeah I do I know he's trying
to get in on the owner ownership side I
would like to see what he can do
whatever money I'm managing a locker
room and scheming because I think that
he knows more about football than maybe
anybody besides Bill Belichick I mean I
would talk about Luke sky Kurt Warner
but he he seems comfortable in the media
right now so that's not happening
anytime here's the thing guys I got
yeah we go coaches I got one that's
gonna blow your mind that's the worst
coach of all time Jeff Fisher college
coach man that yes bring back you hear
about that let him recruit me and being
Luke has some of the same coach of all
time but I think somehow he could just
get a bunch of guys to come in play
really good defense and win and I mean
that's hanging around Nashville ain't
that bad man
no income tax you're doing pretty good
yeah there's better things than that not
when his contract comes into play man
yeah it could be worse recent bullets
new barber and what do we got recently
retired players you know it's funny like
the shop not good players like Kellen
Moore is calling plays for the Cowboys
right now I'm right that's like the
perfect situation yeah like how good is
that good
oh that's winning or that's the guy that
I would expect to be off as a
coordinator it's that's the guy Boise
State guy failed after three years like
didn't fail did okay just wasn't his
thing he wanted to be a coach yeah well
I mean it's like Gardner Minshew that
guy almost rained out oh no no no no I
think men shoes he's he's a player dude
he's like a dude but it was a close call
mhm he really almost hung it up really
almost hung it up Melo what it was
simply GA at Alabama or try to win the
job for Mike Leach at Washington State
and I mean I I read he was really
leaning heavily towards taking that
Alabama spot and getting his career
started in then Mike Leach comes in
probably pitches some crazy [ __ ] in his
ear and it's like okay I'll go try that
now he's starting quarterback in the NFL
he probably would be coaching for Nick
Saban this year had he stayed had he
went to Alabama he chooses Washington
State and now he's a starting
quarterback in the NFL I want to know
why any of the guys on like the Fox for
CBS booth haven't taken the job I think
they just get some run across that table
it's just funny you're making their
money
they're working you know what 40 hours
make normal job yeah yeah family hi kids
I think being a college head coach is
the worst job of all time the review
literally works 365 days a year
yep and and and my one of my agents
Patrick has done that you saw it right
when you were getting recruited he would
say he played at UMass and in Maryland I
mean they're at your house and they're
not your house - right the next guy's
house yeah a nice house that's
exhausting man
there's no dojo talking about it this
week when you're getting like your next
day but you're getting paid a million
dollars a year to do it but is that
worth it I mean this goes back to why
anyone they a lot of people think link
and Riley will consider the Cowboys job
you know eventually you max out of
Oklahoma if Jerry Jones writes you an
eight-year 75 million dollar check yeah
but what if Oklahoma is giving you just
hey you can buy whatever house you want
whatever property that's what you said
and put your kids up anywhere you want
like it's gonna be you want to deal with
the college [ __ ] though you want to deal
with hey these guys are under but then
what if you're making that much to worry
you're paying other guys to do that for
you and you get to be at home there's a
difference when your powerhouse coach
and Lincoln's 36 will be 37 but I think
he's bossy honestly almost putting them
in that territory
I agree but if I'm getting recruited and
he's not there makes you wonder I'm not
going out legit is this I want your face
in the room but I'm not saying that
somehow it works I'm just saying like I
feel like a lot of these guys get
comfortable does that make sense
sure sir maybe why Bob Stoops had a good
night down ya know bob stutes did a lot
for Oklahoma now he's gonna be an exit
felt ledge Mack Brown lot for Texas XFL
don't sleep on it to New York Guardians
face it here st. Louis battle Hawks baby
let's go Hawks Luke Shaw had a range
right are you about no but we gotta bail
Hawks man I don't have any allegiance
yet but I think that I'm probably gonna
have to I'll stick with the Missouri
team I'll go local hey we got Marquette
King as our punter Oh as our punter
he could play receivers people got
the punter can only show votes nope no
more the punter swag man Luke's in New
York hater I'll say that he really is
[ __ ] on the rangers before now he [ __ ]
on the New York Guardians I'm a blues
fan baby yeah you can take the boy out
of Missouri and maybe Missouri out of
the boy this guy's got a Rangers goalie
as his frickin background
I mean Ranger the greatest yeah we're
moving on actually that's a Rangers fan
tone of the [ __ ] this year yeah there's
actually a really good question for Luke
Garrett Greenlee wants to know would you
rather do the Oklahoma trill against
Vince Wilfork in his prime once or it's
a Neil Hunter now three times or sake
one Barkley ten times makes you think
Vince Wilfork one time cuz I don't want
to cook his sake 110 times exactly yeah
the guy's thighs the size of me the
worst option is the Neil Hunter three
times
yeah no I'm doing the one time get it
over with yes good pile drive get
knocked on your ass making a move and do
it in the hole you don't know yeah you
might be able to make a little move to
where he can't hit you square I feel
like she would know I would get past
them and then he just like ripped my
[ __ ] Jersey and I was just get ripped
down and like it would be like I was
like ten pounds like you know I just
pulled down the problem with Vince's man
if he lands on you I mean it's just but
it's getting past them
Oklahoma draw I mean you're going going
Nick you think you're sneaky quick I
think he's getting under you and you're
going down dude maybe if I have like a
barbecue [ __ ] man sake want n times no
thank you I'm not I'm out our next two
hard pass
all right Garrett had the second part of
his question the Giants are seven and
twenty two since taking say Quan Barkley
so if there was a 20-18 redraft how far
would he fall as a Penn State fan
there's no disrespect to say Kwan but
it's clear that a generational talent
doesn't always translate to team success
I
I think that he probably would fall a
lot further than to I I loved him I
think he's one of the best running backs
in the NFL right now but the Giants
aren't finding success they have a lot
of other positions that could have been
feel they need offensive line they need
edge rusher they probably need some
secondary help I love you know Ron back
if you can get them when your teams kind
of already there you look at the the
Cowboys when they took Zeke Elliott they
had a lot of other guys already in peace
in place they got lucky with dak
Prescott but having that running back to
set your team over the top Leonard
fournette has done [ __ ] for the jaguars
he got drafted high you look at se Kwan
I love what he's doing but you can find
running backs later in the draft you can
find an Alvin Kamara late that can get
you over the hump and you can be
successful you don't necessarily need a
running back it - I agree with you but I
don't agree with you I agree with the
fact that like I love when GM's take the
best player available I think that's how
it should work but when that best player
available comes when you have one of the
worst offensive lines in football you
can't take that guy because he's gonna
be screwed I mean like he even though
say Kwan is doing above-average stuff
like you cannot just take him like your
offensive lines
awful and that's what happens when you
take Daniel Jones like you cannot take a
quarterback when your left tackles blind
and I'm not saying that left ankle is
not that good but like yeah he's not
good so I know but like you have to put
like 80 to 100 million dollars in left
tackle and then you draft a quarterback
hence what the Cincinnati Bengals should
do when they draft to it when they make
a right tackle put 80 million dollars
put into whoever you want to draft to a
number one overall and then boom he's
not gonna had that that pressure of that
constant like he's got to step up or
he's got to step out he's got a run or
whatever he's gonna have that oh I can
make my second read I can make my third
wait boom hit AJ Green on a [ __ ] seam
round you know I mean like I I don't
know I just feel like when you draft a
guy in the top ten arounds there needs
to be a reason why you draft them when
it comes to like how your offense or
defense is now if your defense is
terrible and you want to take the best
Claire available I think you should take
the defensive vanity tackle or like you
know the safety if you have like a later
pick but if you got a top five pick I
think and everybody hates that because
everybody wants them to take the
quarterback other running back or
whatever you got to take the offensive
tackle that protects your quarterback
and people forget about that but you
need to put money in your line and then
bring a quarterback in or do that free
agency and then bring a quarterback in
and then boom there they can have time
they get four or five seconds instead of
one or two seconds when chase young or
you know what listen I can't agree with
that I'm not taking a running back at SU
and I don't have a plan in place but how
many running backs have been taken I'm
saying quarterbacks like like the
Dolphins and Cincinnati we're taking to
have a top five pick this year and
they're gonna take quarterbacks the
offensive Lions were terrible man I know
Annie Dalton lost his job this year and
I'm not seeing any dollars the best
quarterback in the world but he wasn't
the problem exactly
that's the thing at least with the
Bengals they had like a plan in place
they took Jonah Williams last year at
tackle he wasn't able to play but I like
what do you have in place I think kind
of taking that offensive lineman first
keeping and protecting your investment
you look at the Chiefs they had a pretty
damn good offensive lining in place they
let Pat mahomes City year I think that's
the way to do it you you can't throw a
guys like Daniel Jones out there with
that offensive line
the Texans tried it with car a long time
ago he almost got killed wasn't able to
do anything that's what the Browns are
doing they got obj they got Jarvis
they got a big job cream hunt and they
got Baker where the [ __ ] the money on
the front [ __ ] five zero there's zero
money I'm not saying they didn't spend a
little bit on a guard or a center but
they just expect all these stars to come
in and just do their thing and then
Baker's running around his head cut off
like how does that work communica
yeah I mean there's countless examples
we could look at it over the years of
guys Mark Bulger in my opinion and you
saw him play was a good quarterback Pro
Bowl quarterback he got
worn out Orlando pace retired didn't
have a job because he got hit
constantly I listen man I I'm just
saying no I'm with you I got that mellow
did you watch that oh yeah I agree with
you I mean Kurt Warner came in and kind
of took that he hates Bulger but I agree
with you you have to pay the offensive
line I think with the Browns you see
that strategy work in the NBA where you
can just go get best available all the
time in the NFL it doesn't work you have
22 positions to fill
you need a scheme in place you need a
plan to where you can get a left tackle
early develop him a little bit I think
that what the Bengals you're gonna see
them take a tackle now they're gonna
take a quarterback then they're gonna
start loading up on receivers maybe get
another running back start building that
defense there's a plan in place Dixon
yeah this guy's good let's pull him in
here AJ Green ain't coming back though
no no he's gone no way you go what I
mean Tyler Boyd's good enough our boys
the Beast yeah Todd Boyd's good enough
man it's tricky it's tricky because
you're only gonna be up there so many
times
that's the angles have to unpick around
all right number one pick and they will
have the number one pick
it's I'm telling you bro it's gonna be
Joe burrow and they don't that's it
who's the best tackle right now on the
board I think Andrew Thomas
technically like I'm from Judea top
three Andrew Thomas
Jedrek wills from Alabama their right
tackle not their left tackle Alex
Leatherwood well it's cuz the right
tackle is cuz it to it yeah that's a
pass for me I would say worse from Iowa
hello
yeah that's who I would have is the top
three but I don't love any of them no
they're not they're not tyrants myths
they're not those kind of guys I don't
know man I'll tell you what they're not
going top two top three it's gonna know
Roche ace young and then you might have
Jeff a coup to go three the corner from
Ohio State that's what kind of draft
we're looking at which is like that's
crazy
we might not have a round one running
back this year maybe DeAndre Swit from
Georgia sneaks in yeah I think a lot of
guys go hide defensively again that
defensive line group looks pretty good
probably gonna have three linebackers in
the first
around where's eoy receiver from Georgia
going is he as well no no he's a
freshman he's a freshman
yep he's a true freshman the one that's
hurt that's not gonna play in the ball
game right yeah the one that got to
season this with SEC championship game
yeah yeah a true freshman George Pickett
yeah because he missed out on the
championship game right no yeah the
first half yeah yeah yeah I mean this
class it's you know there's just not
gonna be a lot of running backs taken
that early and the offensive linemen are
gonna be reaches but I'm with no it's
gonna be defensive guys yeah a lot of
corners a lot of pass rush lot of
tackles Cheban Kinlaw those guys are
gonna go in the top 15 he tackles are
another big thing like I'm you better
find them on day three yeah develop them
hey what happened to Williams the Jets
yeah Leonard what happened next
next up he was traded the Giants no no
no guy Williams yeah yeah
yes he's hurt I know what it's like a
stinger probably Nick after an ankle I
thought that dude was gonna kill
everyone did he was number one for a lot
of people a lot of people you guys have
a good we good we do but yes we have no
skills we can't cover anyone
yeah no offensive line we got no line we
can't cover anyone as you're listening
to this Jess probably lost the 30 by the
Ravens Lamar Jackson well what do you
got on that spreads like 18 now what do
you got on that we usually do a little
film it was doing go ahead Melo we do
blind review every week here Luke we can
close the show out with it
since we're recording before the game we
just go ahead and give our listeners a
little preview of what actually what we
think actually would have happened in
the game so I think the Ravens win big
tonight Lamar Jackson breaks the record
for rushing yards by a quarterback Mike
Vick is there in everybody for the Jets
is hurt no Quinn and Williams no levy on
bail it's gonna be ugly Lamar Jackson
didn't even
in the fourth quarter didn't need him
I'm sorry Connor that you have to live
through this on a Friday morning buddy
but the Ravens look too good all right
I'll pick it up from here I mean let's
be real Lamar Jackson goes for 120
Hollywood Brown catches a long touchdown
Mathieu Don two sacks the Jets offensive
line can't block anyone Adam GaSe is
gonna be back for 2020 no one [ __ ]
knows why I'm still waiting for an
explanation of how he's earned this so
the Jets are embarrassed in Baltimore
final score 32 9 Luke what did you see
from this game man the blind review it's
- it's finally the first thing that's
stumped give me give me a right now all
right we'll pull it up right now
actually let's do the I guess I'm
looking at I'm like I'm gonna spread
right now the Jets are gonna lose oh
thank you I've got a 17 oh yeah me too
Bleacher Report abscess I got the Jets
covering you think it opened at 14 and a
half I know Lamar's got a quad I saw
earlier today at 18 and a half even I
know it went up it started at 14 and a
half like he said like I don't know man
Luke's scared of big spreads that's why
I just spread it all he's scared of big
spreads cuz they they were like not
favored against the Raiders in the
repeat by 30 now you beat the Raiders by
30
that's I'm saying yeah yeah yeah no
you're right I mean it was I don't like
this at all
honestly don't bet this game we have the
first person who hates the blind review
I hate this it's at Baltimore I think
that play skee here all right I want to
know I'm gonna be if I was better this
game I would look into the final review
and how Lamar's doing in this game
because he did not run at all against
Buffalo expression in the second half I
watched that whole entire game and then
we find out that his quads all messed up
so
it makes me think the Jets will cover
I'm the Jester covered you heard it
there
you heard it here Jets lost big but they
cover ya just lost by 15 but they
covered melo you missed it i he was a
big Sam's Arnold fan before mono so
that's there's a little bit of bias into
this yeah before the blonde oh I loved
him too but I mean before Adam case I
think Adam GaSe is more of the problem
people get over mono it's hard to get
over bed you know what I've looked at
their their records to different lately
man not the records they're what David
scoring lately I know they've been
playing honestly they play the Raiders
the [ __ ] the cupcakes care plan
nobody what do the Ravens think this is
a cupcake game is this a trap game I
think this is a trap game the blind
review takes a plot trap game oh [ __ ]
alright that's all we have for draft on
giraffe thank you everyone for your
questions
I'll let Melo and Luke sign off with
their own but thanks for hanging with us
we had a lot of fun today with our
latest co-host our new co-host here Melo
what you got to say goodbye
yeah great show today Luke thank you
very much for joining us man you might
not know it or not yeah but this is not
the last time you would be on stick to
football we've got to get you back on
here I was loving to be back on I had a
great time today
you know if you guys didn't know there's
a little basketball arena in this
headquarters and I won some they know no
moola today so yeah but it was a good
day today I had a fun time I'd love to
come back on these guys are great and I
appreciate you guys alright guys we'll
see you next Monday